welcome to the webinar everyone so in
this webinar we're going to talk about
anti-aging I want to teach you so great
things if to actually reverse aging
process is it possible I think it is
I've been working with a lot of people
over the years and I found that they do
get younger as they get healthier so the
goal is to make you younger every year
that you age so that would be cool um so
um I'm gonna just go to some slides
right now um let me just share my screen
here make sure you can see everything ok
so so here's the thing when we talk
about anti-aging you know if you do
research on the internet you're going to
see there's a lot of information about
just skin creams taking vitamins looking
good on the outside using different
facial scrubs in that type of thing but
there's a lot more to anti-aging than
just a superficial putting a cream on
your face try to get rid of wrinkles so
we're going to talk about two things one
is how to look youthful as you get older
but we're also going to talk about you
know the heart of anti aging which is to
postpone your life to prevent dying in
early age
we're going to talk about that because
it makes no sense to you know try to
look young why you get cancer and
dropped it a heart attack so I'm going
to cover both things today and I wanted
to mention that one of the things that
really emphasized is to increase a
health reserve to build up kind of a
health insurance reserve and there is a
test that can be measured to look at the
internal health reserve and I have one
of my patients that we just today we're
evaluating we're looking at her health
reserve and trying to build that up and
I just want to kind of show you this
little graph here you can see there's a
there's this taller dial in a small dial
the tall dial should be straight up and
down and the small dial should be all
the way to the right so if the small
dial goes to the left that that's
indication that the person is losing
their their kind of their recovery
Reserve and I look at that as kind of
like that the deeper health reserve this
test just to keep it really simple
without giving you a lot of big words is
it's called heart rate variability it's
a test that measures the data in between
the heartbeats it measures how elastic
the heart is it measures how the
heartbeat varies from one beat to
another and it's one of the best
indicators of overall mortality from
heart attacks so I don't use it for that
but it will give a prediction on how
healthy you are overall but also for the
heart the reason I'm bringing this up is
because it probably taken 10,000 of
these graphs and there was only been one
person that has ever had a perfect graph
and he was 80 years old yeah and I'm
like who is this guy he was walking down
the street with his dog he falls in a
hole hit knocks himself out he lays
there for three hours knocked out
unconscious wakes up his head's bleeding
goes back home he has a stiff neck he
sees me three days later his wounds are
almost healed um he has a slight
stiffness in his neck so he had a
perfect perfect graph and I'm like who
the heck is this guy so apparently when
he was younger he took the Olympics in
water polo and he's maintained his
health
ever since that so he could basically
hold his breath three and a half minutes
underwater at this point so out of all
the things all the workouts all the
sports events I would say that water
polo is probably the most incredibly
difficult I almost drowned right up
through the sport in college with my
roommate was into water polo he would
just hold me underneath water until I
let go of the ball he would anchor his
foot into the drain pipe until I you
know cooperated so it's an intense
workout so in other words I'm trying to
just let you know that it is
possible to measure your health reserve
and it is possible to improve it so let
me go to the next slide here so I think
we should probably start this whole
webinar by isolating what are the top
causes of death if you look it up this
is ill they'll go ahead and tell young
WebMD it's the heart disease cancer
chronic respiratory accident stroke
Alzheimer's diabetes influenza pneumonia
nephritis that's kidney problems and
then suicide so those are the top causes
of death but they forgot to mention one
big cause of death and that's probably
the number one it is not probably it is
the number one cause of death and that
is conventional medicine now in the next
slide you can look at the links because
I'll send everyone needs a these PDF
files but the point is that seven
hundred seven hundred thousand people a
year die of reactions to prescription
drugs and necessary antibiotics
unnecessary medical procedures
hospitalizations so that actually ranks
number one so I guess the therapy the
best therapy is to avoid doctors if you
want to live longer probably you know
the question is how many people actually
die the vitamins in 2010 not one person
in 2004 there's three people who died of
mega doses of vitamin D and vitamin E
but I would in their synthetic and of
course the one person died as a result
of overdose with iron and fluoride but I
don't consider fluoride a nutrient so
there's been a huge push you know by
certain people to pretty much make
alternative care dangerous you know it's
quackery it's scams but I personally
think it's just a way to camouflage just
like their own secrets or skeletons
because the amount of medication
Pumped in young children nowadays even
psych drugs that are pushing and the
soldiers there's 23 suicides every
single day in the military and that's
from the side effects and psychiatric
medication so I wanted to just share a
story by a client she told me today she
can you tell us what happened you you
basically went to the doctor and you
wanted some help and you started to you
had a whole list of problems because
we're working with you but there's some
other issues that you wanted to kind of
evaluate can you just tell us a little
bit about you walked in there and you
saw the nurse and what what was the
first thing that she said well um first
I she asked me what I was there for so I
said well I have a list of things and I
had had some symptoms going on so I'd
been keeping track of them and writing
them all down and I started list listing
them off to her and she looked at me
like I was crazy and she said ma'am
you're gonna need to pick the top two
because she's not going to have time to
to deal with all of those issues look
I'm a little shocked like it's like when
you go to a doctor you have a list of
problems all those are connected yes
suffer problems yes yes and that's what
I tried to tell her I said no the
doctors going to need to listen to me
because these are all connected and I
need her to to help me figure out what
is going on so she left the room sort of
hurriedly acting very like almost rude
but when the doctor came in I did make
her sit there and listen to me with
every single one of my symptoms because
they are all connected like you and I
spoke today yeah and so so one of the
things that what's lacking in in health
care I mean look at this you got the top
cause of death is over medicated
patients unnecessary procedures with
everything has become so specialized
into
um if you have a digestive problem you
go to this doctor and er come problem
you go over here but they're not looking
at the whole picture I think even with
you you had I think you had some history
of panic attacks or something right yeah
and they bet what do they what do they
say about that um so I talked to her
about that and told her that I have been
having some panic attacks he basically
said okay so here's a script for you to
go to the psychiatrist and I didn't go
to the psychiatrist and they said okay
well here's some lorazepam or I don't
remember what it was and you know um
there wasn't any let's talk about why
you're having panic attacks or what
might be going on it was well here's
this medicine go ahead and take it so it
was very disheartening and frustrating
yeah yeah I know it's um it's you want
someone to listen to you to a by way to
come up with some solutions
um and then I think you eventually saw
the doctor okay
did he really what did he do did he say
none okay so so as I went through my
list of symptoms he she it was a woman
she says okay so you're having um some
panic attacks and and feeling like this
so here's your referral to go to the see
the psychiatrist and oh you're having
hot flashes okay here's your referral to
go to the gynecologist and oh you're
having some joint pain here's your
referral to oh in your hip and in your
back so here's your referral to go get
some x-rays done oh you're you're having
constipation so take some fiber thing
you know what I'm it just she was
treating each one of the things as as a
symptom as opposed to as opposed to
looking at everything that was going on
that's going on with me as a whole that
there might be something happen
um she just singled each of them out and
sent me to other places and tried to
treat each symptom individually yeah and
that's why I wanted to do this webinar
just to give you guys some real basic
things I mean even one thing with you
with your hip
I did some muscle testing I found out I
asked you a question I said do you cross
your leg a lot on one side and yes you
do yeah I mean you constitute and then
that's the muscle that is weak because
you keep crossing it and throws off the
pelvis so um the some of these things
are really really really um 'is obvious
but the problem is those are the
sometimes hardest to identify so I
wanted to get through so I'm going to
come back to that point but I want to
just go through a couple things about
the third leading cause of death since
we're trying to live longer because I I
kind of protest getting old I don't want
to get old
I know it's inevitable but I want to
slow it down but it's important to kind
of know what people die of that they're
losing leading cause of death after
heart disease and cancer is psychiatric
medications I didn't even know that I
looked that up and this is um in the
cancer in USA and Europe over a half a
million people die of either suicide or
psychiatric medication that reactions to
that I think that's why the drug
companies are being sued by the billions
so there's a lot of corruption going on
with psychiatric drugs in the military
all over the place and then you have
this guy Stephen Barret Beret whatever
his name is in quack watch which
basically says he says most diseases
have a little of nothing to do with diet
it's not um and he goes into saying that
it's most things are placebo you know
don't take vitamins
you know alternative practitioners
oversimplify he says when they say that
milling that's like rindy grain removes
the B vitamins they don't bother to tell
you the enrichment
and back so you can see that here is a
person who is very anti natural vitamins
he's a psychiatrist which causes the
third leading cause of death there's no
it's just a joke so the philosophy that
I wanted to teach you guys today is
really going beyond the outside in and
going the inside out working on the
inside of your body if you want this the
entire body to look youthful I think
probably the one of the biggest in your
seat industries out there is skincare
and makeup and hair care and it's all
just superficial you're just dealing
with a layer of a very tiny layer on the
outside of your body
there is much better things to do to get
the skin youthful prevent wrinkles and
I'm going to cover what you need to do a
better strategy would be to just really
look at the quality of materials that
you're putting in your mouth and your
digesting I will say that certain parts
of your body are replaced at different
rates for example like your your skin
cells sometimes you replace every four
days the liver is replaced every three
years so the red blood cells are
replaced every four months the colon
cells are replaced every three days so
you're constantly replacing your cells
and the question is what are you
replacing them with I'm going to show
you the best material to replace them
with but there's one thing that doesn't
rejuvenate or doesn't replace itself and
that's the brain so once you kill off
your brain cells you don't replace them
they don't come back so what I want to
do is I want to ask everyone who's on
the webinar um a question what food and
I'm going to just make this what is the
food that gives us the highest nutrient
value okay it's a category of foods and
I want you to go ahead and I'm looking
at your answers right now
want you to take a well guess what
category of food gives you the highest
amount of nutrition out of all food
categories I'm going to give you a
second to answer that okay kale leafy
greens vegetables kale veggies plants
protein fats veggies protein okay well
this is interesting because this is
something that's kind of unknown um yeah
berries no I always like that when you
ask a column in I'll ask a question I'll
say um okay does anyone know this and
you know they're not going to know it so
you just know that's not right so you're
wrong you're wrong you're wrong so um
what about you you have any idea what
Leslie would what the highest nutrient
food is on the planet that you can get
all of your nutrition I should know this
ah I'm thinking um I'm thinking yeah I
don't know why but I could be wrong all
right let me I mean I'm eating all the
things on the side everybody's saying
good stuff yeah oh sure the one that one
thing I'm not sure what the one thing
with me um okay so now I'm going to tell
you um it is I thought I had slide on it
but I don't organ meats oregon means up
then yeah liver heart brains kidneys for
it personally um I can't eat those foods
I just I just can't eat them I think I
was as a child that was forced to eat
liver and I just can't eat it I don't
know I have a hard time eating brains
and kidneys but I'm just letting you
know those foods I know a lot of them
are toxic because of the animal feeds
but I'm just telling you as far as the
nutrients that are in those foods like
it's it's really hard to find one food
that has all the nutrients but there is
one food that has all the
and that would be the organ meats so if
you like liver and you have an organic
or free-range you know animal and you
consume that it's not you will get a lot
of nutrition especially like iron and
there is one type of nutrient types of
vitamin e treants that are better for
looking young young than others and that
would be the fat soluble vitamins and
that would be like vitamin A D e K those
vitamins yes they're in vegetables but
they're actually in vegetables they're
pre vitamins so in other words they have
to convert into the active form and you
have to have a good digestive system to
consume that so you may if you're lucky
convert about 5% of those true fats and
vitamins to help division to the skin
even vitamin A for your skin if you
don't have vitamin A you actually dry
out your skin you and you actually look
older going on a low-fat diet is very
very bad for anti-aging so let's go into
some of the the foods or the nutrients
that will help you stay younger or look
younger the first thing I want to talk
about is foods for college and support
whisk collagen collagen is like the glue
that holds the body together it's the UM
it's in the joints it's in the skin if
you lose collagen your skin gets thin
and it sags and you get wrinkles and you
look older so you can consume the
collagen itself or bone broth or
grass-fed animal products but you also
need trace minerals to actually utilize
that collagen you also need vitamin C to
use the collagen so I wanted to show you
something this is a grass-fed collagen
that I got online Great Lakes gelatin I
mean it's it's good if you have like a
lot of joint problems arthritis and you
don't consume
a lot of animal products especially
grass-fed that would be something you
can try and but I found that most people
are not really deficient in collagen
it's not something that are not eating
that's not why they're losing your
collagen I'll get to the why but the
point is that it's not a bad supplement
to take but just by taking this doesn't
is does not mean your skin's going to
look youthful you need several things to
to make that work um the big thing is
trace minerals as trace minerals are not
in the soils I've done seminars on trace
minerals use a version I use trace
minerals it's a plant-based it's not sea
salt plant-based minerals have our fifty
fifteen thousand times smaller than
regular minerals so they it go in like a
rocket ship so you need the minerals you
also need the vitamin C complexes and I
I wanted to show you a food that's very
high in vitamin C but I want to first
find out I'm going to ask you what foods
are high in vitamin C what are the top
three foods that are the highest in
vitamin C let's see who can get that one
right
okay people are saying camu camu yeah
that's a great citrus carrots broccoli
kale spinach so you guys you you guys
are doing pretty good on that one
so I think you got that one down there
the three foods at the highest in
vitamin C which would be number one up
ayah number two Kiwi and number three
peppers now these are not from the
grocery store these are from the farmers
market
these are freaking amazing peppers
they're crunchy there's they're loaded
with vitamin C and vitamin C you got to
be careful about vitamin C because most
of it is synthetic and I'm talking about
ascorbic acid if you buy Ottoman C and
it has over 100 milligrams of ascorbic
acid it's just synthetic they make
ascorbic acid from corn starch which has
no vitamin C in sulfuric acid and you
take this stuff you're not getting any /
C complex it's not going to help your
collagen if you do something like this
you're going to get the complete complex
because in the complete version of
vitamin C you have enzymes a copper
enzyme called tyrosinase you have the J
factor the bioflavonoids
the route ins all the different great
complexes provided and C to help build
collagen and organic copper it's a
mineral in that thing and so it's and by
the way a lot of the drought the vitamin
C is stored in your adrenal glands so
the dream glands are tired you won't
have enough vitamin C to use that and
the other thing is that when you take
vitamin C in high dosages and synthetic
versions it will create deficiencies of
the other factors about and C causing
spider veins and I'm going to talk more
about this in the next seminar but Linus
Pauling recommend large dose of vitamin
C
notice he has these spider veins around
his nose that's a vitamin C deficiency
because one of the side effects of
scurvy is micro hemorrhaging of the
capillary blood beds and so the scoop
the bleeding gums the spongy gums that
you have when you brush your teeth
that's a vitamin C deficiency so and
also fatigue is a vitamin C deficiency
but also the arteries the arteries can
in high-pressure areas have a micro
hemorrhage hemorrhage and so the body
puts a bandaid on it called cholesterol
and calcium plaquing and that's what
makes the clogged artery but the first
thing that happens is the micro damaged
hemorrhage from the vitamin-c complex
deficiency so those are some vitamin C
things that you can look at and
especially for your skin I mean you need
that collagen so now I'm going to go
back to my slide if I can do a screen
share let me see here okay so we have
collagen bone broth if you took an org
let's say some bones from and um let's a
cow or something and it was grass-fed
and you were to cook it over a day or
two and make some bone broth and there's
a great recipe that would not be a bad
idea to drink that stuff it's really
good for collagen especially if you want
really strong nails and hair um I can
actually if I can either use trace
minerals to make hair stop falling out
or sometimes collagen or the combination
of both but because trace minerals also
help the collagen form correctly so the
combination is very very important
especially for a hair loss so the most
important thing to do is to make sure
that your animal meats are grass-fed and
I'm going to show you I use them like
here's an example I do a lot of beef
myself this is grass-fed um and the
reason why I do
grass-fed is because it has loaded with
vitamin k2 if you've seen any of my
videos you basically know about k2 it's
going to be the next super vitamin it
improves elasticity of the arteries it
decreases blood pressure it gets calcium
out of the joints it's quite amazing and
of course we have the grass-fed
Kerrygold butter that's vitamin K it's
loaded with vitamin A and of course I'm
showing all my food here um these are my
eggs from the farmers market from a
farmer that basically I have a video I'm
going to put a video of this farmer
because he has these cages in the grass
field in the clover fields and they're
like the human lawn mower they will eat
all this grass and then he rotates them
I mean talk about a pasture raised
grass-fed chicken I mean those things
are those eggs it's hard to even break
the shell it's silt loaded with calcium
so it's quite amazing um there's a
couple questions I want to just go right
to the questions um said the webinar
keeps cutting out nope no worries I'm
going to record this and I'll send you
the link right when I get done what
about fermented cabbage I love it I
think that's a great idea and vitamin I
mean cabbage is is really huge in
vitamin C and it has a complete complex
can spider veins be repaired by taking
proper amounts of vitamin C well I
wouldn't worry about the amounts I would
worry about the type of vitamin C that
you consume and yes it can be reversed
if you have the whole complex just make
sure you do not consume ascorbic acid um
let's see what else grapefruit has some
vitamin C but it's a bit too sweet if
you're trying to lose weight I always
have to talk about that because fruit
tends to slow down weight loss okay good
what what if you have autoimmune and
can't do nitrates well then you can use
the you know there's camu camu is a
great vitamin c complex you can do that
there's a lot of other things that you
can do other than nitrates not a problem
okay so there's three things for
collagen support
one is you need you possibly might need
collagen you might need trace minerals
and you you might need to support your
your stomach because if your stomach has
um if you have like acid reflux or you
have bloating or burping and you don't
have enough acid that could be the
reason why you can't digest protein and
collagen is your stomach has to be
really really acid to to trigger those
enzymes in the stomach to break down
collagen so as you get older especially
during menopause you lose your stomach
acids so if I were trying to improve my
collagen and I was female and I was
menopausal the first thing I would do
before anything is I would make sure
that I correct on that digestive stomach
pH so if I had like indigestion or s
reflux or heartburn that means that I
would have to add more acid to that
stomach to correct it so the valve gets
closed called betaine hydrochloride so
if you're listening now and you have any
digestive issues at all
take some betaine hydrochloride maybe
three with a meal get it from the help
of store and then within a week or two
watch what happens to your hair nails
and skin it will improve because you'll
start absorbing more of the collagen
from the food you're already eating so
we just have to look at those factors
the next thing I want to talk about is
very important and this is for those
people that want to change the not just
their health but the looking youthful
and that would be the fat soluble
vitamins and all the oils you don't want
to go crazy you have to be able to
digest them
you need to have a good gallbladder to
digest them but the point is that when
people are pushing the low fat stuff
that's when you start looking older you
want to look at the shelf and get whole
fat not low fat anything so if you're
going to do some yogurt you know make
sure it's whole fat of course you go
watch out for the sugars and yogurt
nowadays um so there's not a problem
using the butter it's good for the skin
because it contains vitamin A so the
first item I'm going to talk about is
vitamin A and that is in egg yolks
grass-fed butter shrimp cheese sardines
to nuts and fish it's in all the fatty
stuff I'll show you something here um
I'm going to show oh yeah cheese I'm
from Wisconsin
so I love cheese and of course Kerrygold
here we go Kerry gold butter Kerry gold
cheese this is my favorite cheese right
here it's at BJ's in Costco now I can't
believe it it's all grass-fed here's
another grass-fed cheese from Trader
Joe's I do a lot of cheese that has the
vitamin K it has a vitamin A even even
some vitamin D those are fat soluble
vitamins that you need for your skin for
your hair to prevent wrinkles so those
are things that will really really help
you and take them from the inside don't
rub the butter on the outside of your
skin that's not going to do it I used to
crave butter as a kid I used to eat it
of course I had no idea why now I know
why I was deficient in vitamin A hmm so
so vitamin A it's in these fattier type
things that you were told to avoid
mm-hmm so the other thing you can do is
up coconut oil you can cook with it you
can eat it fish oils
the best fish oil that you can have is
either krill or cod liver oil yes
your grandmother was correct cod liver
oil has a wonderful blend of vitamin A
and vitamin D so don't I mean just I
would start consuming just you don't
need a lot of it you just need a little
bit of it okay
now let's talk about vitamin E why is
vitamin E important you've heard vitamin
E for scarring for skin health for sex
hormones vitamin E is a precursor for
hormones and it's stored in the
pituitary when women go through
menopause they don't use their ovaries
very much anymore so they're not going
to baby so what happens is that that
dynamic that pituitary release every
month is no longer it no longer has to
work as hard so the vitamin E reserve
tends to dry up in a lot of women and I
find they end up with a vitamin E
deficiency and they start getting
unnecessary wrinkles so I fire you what
I would do is I would don't be afraid to
start consuming some of these fats but
the foods that are highest in vitamin E
are almonds other nuts sunflower seeds
very high but they have to be raw
sunflower seeds because when you cook
them and you roast them you destroy the
vitamin E because vitamin E is very
sensitive to oxygen and heat okay fatty
your fish like halibut salmon shrimp
sardines lobster um and it's also in the
leafy greens the spinach chard kale some
eggs it's an avocado so it's an olives
so those are just some some common
things course vitamin D is the Sun fish
oils eggs cheese um but other than that
let's say you're not eating any
officials or eggs or cheese because
you're in a low-fat diet you don't get
much Sun and you're going to low vitamin
D levels vitamin D is necessary for the
aging anti-aging
process okay so what I'm going to do now
is I just want to double check just to
make sure that there's I'm answering any
questions so someone says they love
sardines cow's milk allergy well if you
have if you're allergic to you know milk
not a problem I've given you a list of
other things you consume as well
dandelion greens for vitamin A yeah well
the the problem is the plant sources
provide them an a they're all pre
vitamin A so you're only going to absorb
five percent and that is the challenge
that we do if now I consume a lot of yes
kale okay I eat kale I cut it chop it up
my salad so that's loaded with vitamin
pre vitamin A but it's C the cruciferous
vegetables have other nutrients we'll
get into that but the point is that you
need to be eating them but you're not
going to be getting the majority of your
vitamin A from leafy greens because you
only absorb 5% yeah I'm sorry
okay let me just check these questions
right here
um you say BJ's has good caracal yes
BJ's does carry the Kerrygold in bulk so
yes tuna is is fine I know there's some
problems with mercury um but I think
there's certain time I'm actually going
to do a video on tuna because there's
certain types of tuna that are actually
good and some tuna that it's not good
I'm going to do a complete video because
I don't want to get into a side thing on
that right now
fermented cod liver oil is the best and
you can get that online you can get it
from Amazon I do take that it's pretty
good um I was given cod liver oil when I
was a kid
lasted until Easter yeah it's really
good stuff um
I found I sweat really bad with out my
vitamin D interesting graying of the
hair mostly after exercise well that's a
stress see one of the things that we'll
get into next is stress so I'll talk
about that then can you get enough
vitamin D from foods you need supplement
that's a very good question I think you
can maintain your body with just with
vitamin k2 foods but if you have high
blood pressure stiffness you have tartar
on the teeth soft tissue calcium you
have arthritis or types of joint
problems then you're going to have to
take extra and then once you get rid of
that you can then maintain it after that
so it is possible but not as a maintain
maintaining thing okay now I'm going to
show you something
see if I can pop back over here now the
accelerated aging of cortisol the
hormone cortisol here's a new word that
I want to teach you is called catabolism
catabolism what does that mean
catabolism catabolism is a breakdown of
things it's something that breaks down
in the body your body naturally uses the
hormone cortisol to break down tissue
but with the adrenal stress hormone
being activated what happens is you get
too much breakdown and not enough build
up so you get this overall catabolic
effect that means a breakdown effect on
the on the muscles specifically your
thigh muscles in the quad group so when
you get up from a seated position or
from a chair it might be difficult to
mount this time to get up also the skin
is very thin and almost paper like and
I'll see that with people I'll look at
their skin you can just see it's like
very very very thin that's that's the
problem of excessive cortisol with
stress and you're losing your collagen
you also have a disappearance of the
elastic fibers and that's why your
joints it's so brittle all the time as
you age and that's just one of the
effects of of course
now I did a whole seminar on cortisol
that was the last seminar I did and I
talked about stress and if you did not
see that webinar go ahead and watch it
but I will give you some tips on stress
right now because I would say one of the
biggest things that ages people is
stress specifically losses loss of a
person loved one loss of a job loss of a
marriage threat of loss financial threat
of loss bad economy all that will add
stress and so you do have to constantly
work on reducing corners so there's a
couple nutritional things that I
recommend for cortisol I do recommend
the adrenal day formula because it has a
natural b1 and there that does not it's
from nutritional use but it doesn't give
you a yeast infection like some of the
nutritional yeast out there and it's not
synthetic like a lot of the nutritional
yeast are enriched with synthetic so if
you did um a that product and you take
the that natural b1 with all the other
things in it it'll tend to pull a lot of
stress out your body you feel very very
calm and chilled out so b1 is necessary
to rid stress from your body and you'll
feel a difference how do you know if you
have a b1 deficiency there's a couple
ways number one you feel a lot of
nervous tension in your body you just
like you can't relax you have a low
tolerance to stress you have a Deema and
swelling yes a demon swelling is that b1
deficiency many times as well you have
nightmares where very vivid dreams so if
you have any of those we know it's a
it's a b1 deficiency and stress will
cause that another thing you can do is
get space go up for long walks because
stress tends to inhibit your space and
you get it's like you need to get
outside and just get some space because
that calms the adrenal gland down you're
just a picture of how proteins and
different things can break down fat can
break down sugars can break down call it
catabolism and just a breakdown
okay we're shifting gears now to cancer
control because one of the things that
um which is a process is dying early
from cancer I mean there are people all
around me that are dropping dead with
cancer patients patients relatives
family members so it is a problem and
there are things that we can do to
reduce the risk of cancer and I want to
talk about that um let's first define
what cancer is cancer is a cell that is
out of control it's it's duplicating at
a very fast rate and the question is why
there's a mechanism a machine in your
body that is constantly keeping these
extra cells that are radically growing
out of proportion in check so there's a
there's another word I'm going to teach
you it's called apoptosis apoptosis and
that that's basically controlled cell
death your body is killing between 50
and 70 billion cells every single day
which they need to do that because they
need to clean out all these you know
mutated cells the cells that we need to
get rid of so we can replace with the
new cells so for an average trial
between the ages of 8 and 14 about 20
billion to 30 billion cells die a day so
that's called apoptosis so now if we
have if we're getting cancer we want
apoptosis to work correctly to kill that
cancer so apoptosis is a mechanism
that's an important defense against
cancer okay so that's
the foundation I want to talk about so
there's certain things that dis destroy
this mechanism in block the your body's
ability to kill off these cells and
there's certain things that do it and
this slide is out of order
it's called endocrine disruptors so I
want to just touch on this for a second
what's an endocrine disruptor an
endocrine disruptor is any chemical in
the body pesticide herbicides fungicides
insecticides heavy metals
country-and-western just wanna see if
you guys are awake
that was a joke that was a dry sense of
humor heavy metals country-western was a
bad joke okay so endocrine disruptors
are any chemicals in environment that
alter your genes and cause disease
there's these I have this book it's
about three inches thick it's called the
modern text toxicology's the basically
the textbook of poisons okay the study
of poisons and what poisons do with it
to the body
we are bathed in so many chemicals it's
it's insane from walking out in the yard
to our food to the air we're just bathed
in all these chemicals I mean there's
over four billion pounds of toxic
chemicals releasing into our environment
every single year that's 72 million
pounds of recognized carcinogens which
actually cause cancer so our bodies are
constantly hit with these endocrine
disruptors okay well guess what these
endocrine disruptors mess up the normal
process of your body controlling cancer
so you may have known that already but
I'm just refreshing your your mind I'm
just touching right now I want to see if
there's any questions real fast because
oh yeah someone mentioned des
diethylstilbestrol here's a there's a
tongue twister diethylstilbestrol was
used in the 50s from
morning sickness I think over like
millions of women were exposed to it and
it caused problems not just in the
offspring but in the third generation it
it really destroyed our bodies and they
did not test the long-term effects of
that very very similarly to what they're
doing now with the GMO foods so they
made a lot of money and then now they
banned it
okay that's des so des is called
endocrine disruptor destroys your how
your hormones okay so now this really
amazing car called the cytochrome p450
now I'm just this is another bad joke
but it sounds like a car doesn't at p450
now a cytochrome p450 is an enzyme that
has incredible capacities to turn those
endocrine disrupters those poisons into
harmless particles yeah so cytochrome
p450 enzymes are these special enzymes
in your liver and they're in different
cells in your body that can break down
thousands of chemicals toxins drugs and
poisons and they basically just turn
them into water-soluble particles that
can go through the urine and it just so
happens that the cruciferous vegetables
increase your livers ability to make
this enzyme that's really cool so here
it is right here insecticides pesticides
going to the liver and your liver if
you're eating the right foods will
basically dismantle those chemicals so
your liver is like robust but if you
have a fatty liver or it's a liver
that's a bad liver from some type of
virus or something then what's going to
happen is that you're not going to get
that breakdown how do you know if you
have a fatty liver um a lot of people
have it and they don't know it one of
the biggest clues is your stomach being
too big and that's causing visceral fat
around the organs and especially the
liver
I sent five of my patients to the
radiologist to get an ultrasound of the
liver and they all have guts in five
hundred a fatty liver so when you lose
the capacity for liver
you can't detoxify as well and you get a
lot more toxicity and what do you have
to do if you have that condition you
have to basically start consuming a lot
of cruciferous and avoid the junk you
need to get the junk out of the trunk
all right so if someone check the
questions here dr. Berg isn't it more of
a function of minerals actually being in
the soil before you can assume that
they're part of the plant in a plant or
an animal that is eat it yes well that's
why I really want to consume grass-fed
animal products because our soils are so
bad now that we need to and that you
feed these animals corn and soy they're
not getting a nutrition from that at all
and it's all genetically modified so at
least if it's grass it doesn't it's not
genetically modified if you have a lot
more nutrition in the grass especially
like clover okay okay let's go back to
the slides here okay at the liver very
important with with your skin if you
really work on your liver and you start
consuming a lot more of these
cruciferous vegetables your skin will
start to change and you'll start looking
better and better and better especially
with acne and dry skin and youthful skin
I mean the liver is really the hub of
all the digestion of of your amino acids
your proteins so we're going to talk
about cruciferous for a second let me
just fix the slide here cruciferous what
does this moot word mean Chris crus
which means cross it's basically certain
plants that have these little crosses in
them okay and here's some examples of
cruciferous radishes Brussels sprouts
kale cabbage bok choy and Swiss chard
mustard greens arugula now I have some
other vegetables in here too but I
wanted just to mention the cruciferous
family and this is this brings me to the
next topic which is going to call um
which is a different type of nutrient we
talked about the fat soluble vitamins
but we now we need to talk about the
other nutrient that will not just help
your skin and all that but it will help
postpone your life cruciferous was
studied by the World Health Organization
and it was found to create some serious
anti-aging effects and anti-cancer
effects on your body each type of food
is thoroughly tested to decrease the
risk factors of many different types of
cancer so one type of cruciferous will
maybe handle like several type of
cancers another one will handle a
different other ones garlic is probably
the top of the list that probably will
that's like the most anti-cancer
properties these are two different types
of kale tumeric is a an amazing final
nutrient it has phytonutrients I'm sorry
turmeric is kind of a root that has
phytonutrients so the category of
nutrients that we want to talk about
next is called phytonutrients plant
chemicals these are different than
vitamins and minerals and amino acids
they basically are natural plant
chemicals that have extra health factors
or properties so they're there like
they'll actually help with macular
degeneration prostate cancer many
disease states and so the question is
why are not what why are we eating these
foods I mean very few people consume
these foods here's some good ones
parsley cabbage and seek help seek help
is great for minerals and iodine um but
these are the foods that I consume on a
regular
basses if you don't consume them you
need to start doing it for your liver
and your skin will start to change as
well even though these do not contain a
lot of the fat soluble vitamins they do
contain a lot of the phytonutrients
which there are anti-cancer and again
the GMO foods genetically modified foods
are basically spreading all over the
world right now and the two big ones are
corn and soy and the animals that are
consuming these are getting all sorts of
inflammatory conditions and even the the
pets that you have like even the dogs
and the cats if you talk to a vet on
these animals that come in with
arthritis heart disease diabetes and
inflammation in the gut it's because
they're consuming GMO food when you just
simply change the food not on GMO these
things clear up but 90% of all the GMO
corn and soy go to animal feeds that's
pretty sad so in the grocery store that
so-called natural chicken that you have
from Purdue it's all GML unless it says
organic it's GML now what does GMO GMO
is genetically modified organisms and
what they do is they they actually have
them resistant to the herbicide called
Roundup Ready and so you can spray more
the Roundup Ready on these crops and so
you bet they do that and it's around
already the chemical name is called
glyphosate and glyphosate is um pretty
nasty stuff but of course they say it's
safe so I think it might be okay um
there's this French researcher by the
way that was just a sarcasm um sometimes
people don't get my dry humor I don't
think they're safe but there's this
French researcher who did studies animal
studies and glyphosate and he found some
serious problems with glyphosate and I'm
on a semi I'm going to send you the link
to it says that GMO and glyphosate
causes tumors liver and
any damage and rats within a week a
smear campaign was mounted by the
biotechnology industry with scientists
primarily plant biologists and not
toxicologists and they basically forced
this study to be extracted from some of
these journals so here the study comes
out saying that GMO is bad and then it
instantly was retracted not because they
didn't find a cancer link but their
reasoning was it was inconclusive
because the type of rats used were prone
to tumors so now here's the thing if
they can do that you know that how
they're so powerful they are so powerful
so um I mean you can this is totally
political so the point is that you know
the GMO food is pretty bad if you look
at from 1990 to 2012 you can see how
many millions of pounds of glyphosate is
being put or GMO plants are being
created and you can see corns going up
soybeans is going up wheat actually some
of the wheat is genetically modified
cotton uh certain vegetables and fruit
rice grapes
alfalfa pasture and hay other crops oh
my gosh it's just kind of going up it's
just crazy
so what happens is these chemicals GMO
foods herbicides they can mimic hormones
and they go into your glands that die
right the ovary and it can go into the
breasts the uterus and cause cancer so
if you take a look at like they always
say that disease is so mysterious and it
no one knows what causes this take a
look at any of the toxicology books they
will list all the diseases and tell you
what pesticide or chemical causes this
illness or this cancer and they don't
really like you said Leslie they they do
not connect the dots they don't
Connect toxicology with cancer and
natural things everything is like their
own Island and so it's very obvious to
me that all these things that are
related to the toxins and we we don't
actually we're not making the connection
there of course we have psychiatrists
like Stephen Barret without beret
whatever his name is pushing out there
that oh no that's fine just keep eating
the stuff I was a released a video I was
on sports talk live and I had a
dietitian and her husband was an MD get
on the air and give me a hard time about
the whole water meth so you can watch it
on my website but um it was ridiculous
there's like oh yeah the tap water's
fine it has minerals to keep drinking it
everyone's dehydrated I'm like yeah okay
alright so you just see the next slag
here okay be the hormones like estrogen
from the environment and all these
endocrine disrupters act like estrogen
in the environment they actually block
the thyroid function so endocrine
disrupters basically are chemicals that
mimic estrogen and that's why females it
way way too many cancers in the in the
areas that they have receptors for
estrogen which are breast uterus and
even the thyroid african-american women
have a lot more receptors for estrogen
which gives them a different shape and
that's one of the reasons why even
African American women are getting more
cancers than other cultures because of
the estrogen so you really need to
increase your cruciferous make sure you
do consume things that are you know make
sure they're organic hormone-free
because it's going to create a problem
sooner or later so I just wanted to put
this slide up I had it created you can
see if you go down the grocery store you
see these incredible I
delicious cookies and doughnuts and
breads it's all the same ingredients I
purchased corn syrup hydrogenated oils
chemicals high-fructose corn syrup
artificial flavoring it's all the same
thing pretty sad
so phytonutrients those are plant-based
chemicals that have all these really
amazing properties and all these
different plant chemicals that do many
things like even vitamin A for example
vitamin A is not a single vitamin it's a
whole bunch of complexes like there's
over 600 parts of vitamin A so if you
take a synthetic vitamin A you are not
even getting close to what you should
get that's what I'm very much against
synthetics so cruciferous vegetables
help protect the cells from DNA damage
they help inactivate carcinogens they're
antiviral antibacterial
anti-inflammatory I mean they create all
these wonderful benefits now I'm going
to check check the questions here what
do you think of wild yam well if you um
have a problem with hot flashes with
menopause I think that would be
something you should take because that
will it's a natural source of it's
called phyto estrogens which are
actually will help you there's some
other ones to call the clover leaf
that's actually very good as well um
let's see okay how much difference will
it take to take a cruciferous supplement
um here's the thing it's always best to
consume the food but it is hard to get
that so what I'm going to show you is a
the cruciferous product that a lot of
you are already taking right now and of
course you probably have not been taking
because I've been out of it since March
but I wanted to explain kind of a
combination of
ingredients that I'm not even I'm just
but I'm not even showing this image here
okay so you can see right here there's a
product that I I created it's called the
Creuset organic cruciferous food and it
has organic beetroot Brussels sprouts
collard green organic asparagus organic
kale organic parsley and parsley is
probably even has more vitamin of
vitamins and kale and then we have
organic red radish cabbage garlic and
tamarick so those are all the things
that I personally think are the the
superfoods and I put them in in one
combination was 250 tablets in this and
this is something that is convenient if
you don't have all the different variety
of nutrients because it is hard to get
all these nutrients so like it has all
these these products in there has seek
help because some people we go because
oh my gosh is there's cruciferous it's
going to cause a deficiency of iodine
for my thyroid I'm gonna get a quarter
no you're not
I put the sea kelp in there so it's a
really awesome product and and in these
webinars I always get people at discount
if you wanted to get some cruciferous um
the bottle is 250 capsules and here's I
have some good news and some bad news
what do you want to hear at first the
bad news or the good news let me see
what you guys say there's a delay in
this thing okay Leslie us you want the
good news or the bad news
um bad news look at good news
okay good the good news is that I'm
giving you a discount on this product
$10 off and here's the coupon code and
here's the link and the good news is
that it's fun it's almost in
News is not in yet it's in tomorrow
morning's coming tomorrow morning so but
the good news it's almost in and I've
had people wait since March for this
product because because here's the
problem I ran into um it is almost
impossible to find a local farmer or
something United States that has the
soils that I want to get these products
unless you go to China or you go to some
other country I don't I don't do that so
it's taken us forever and so what will
happen this is March March March April
May June July August is it August or
September September ok that's seven
months I haven't had this product I'm
getting it tomorrow morning it's coming
tomorrow morning Percy so what happened
is I would get it would have like one
ingredient tested would be it would have
too much lead in it and like I can't do
that and next one I have like too much I
don't know another mineral that we don't
want in there that's toxic or something
like that so we had the thoroughly test
every single ingredient and make sure
that it's all really really high quality
from the exact farms that I wanted it
from so it's finally done so the good
news it's almost here the bad news is
not quite here and so um there's some
more bad news which I'm going to tell
you right now the other bad news is that
um the cost of this product went up
severely so I have to increase it a
little bit more so that going to be five
dollars more but the good news is if you
wanted to get the product at the lowest
fee you can actually buy as many of
these as you want with on this on this
webinar so that's the good news so you
don't have to pay the big raphy if you
don't want so you can get some reserve
if you want the only catch-22 is that I
only want you to order this tomorrow
morning not tonight because I do not
want to sell you
is product unless I am 100 percent sure
it's available yeah even though I'm
tracking I'm tracking the guy who's like
pulling up in my offices I know what
state he's in he's going to be showing
it tomorrow but until it shows up I'm
not going to take I'm not going to take
the block off my website so no there was
no one can really buy it until I
actually have it in hand so if you
wanted to check in early the morning in
an infant actually everything works then
it's in if it doesn't work then you know
it's not in yet so I just want to let
you know that I've been really behind
the scenes trying to get this thing out
for a long time so so the good news is
I'll have it in tomorrow is a 99.99%
chance and the bad news is it's a little
bit more expensive but the good news is
you don't have to pay that because I'm
giving you a discount so anyway this is
a good product to take for your liver
it's the best anti-aging because it
fortifies the inside of the body and it
also protects against a lot of different
types of conditions that people are at
risk just from the pollution in the
environment so so now what I want to do
is I want to give you a link and a code
coupon code you can just highlight that
coupon code and just yeah just save it
for tomorrow and you can go to my
website and get a discount you get as
many as you want
I I will be increasing lean the prices
already increase but if you use that
discount which is going to be good for
the next three days I know it says the
offer ends in one hour but that's not
true because I don't even have the
product in so no worries on that okay
now if you are watching this as a
webinar replay just realize I already
have it in okay because
I'll have it in by tomorrow for sure
um someone says can I piggyback on
auto-ship order with my wheatgrass juice
yes I think you could do that but you
may want to call my office with that
how long is to keep an offer for the
next three days how long is the
shelf-life
the shelf-life is is good for a year but
I think it's actually longer than that
but we we tell people a year at the
because we're being very conservative
mm-hmm someone says don't go to
commercial I'm not I'm not going to
commercial don't worry I'm just good
people asking me I'm giving them a
discount um can you provide the price of
the hoaxers food yeah
the price was thirty thirty 4.95 now
it's 39.95 but there's two hundred and
fifty capsules in there um but the
problem is that the the price trying to
get these ingredients is off the charts
even if you go look for a cruciferous
product it's hard to find um all these
cruciferous and you may find them like
in like broccoli or something like that
but it's only like 90 pills and it's
probably it's going to be the same it's
like thirty dollars it's the same thing
so it's it is a good a good program with
with the quantity that you're getting
into quality as well if you shift
candidate yes do they lose any vitamins
when they are processed um well you're
not going to lose that much with the
processing but if you keep them in the
heat they keep it open you may even want
to keep in the fridge to have them last
a lot longer
what is the dosage how many pills per
day it depends if you want to make
maintenance dose I would take three but
if you want to correct something you
want to take six personally this is just
my own opinion if I had cancer I would
take 15 a day
Wow I've had a lot of people that just
take them for weight loss but that's
just because it improves the
the the fat release on the liver and it
allows the liver to function better
which is really connected to actually a
thyroid being working better but so it
doesn't actually burn fat by itself um
what if you have a thyroid problem well
we have seek help in there so you have
the I then that's not going to be a
problem is it safe to take if you're
pregnant absolutely because there's
there's nothing else but those
ingredients can I give it to my toddler
depends if he's like 1 or older just
give them maybe one a day but of course
if it's a baby you're not going to give
him that unless he can swallow capsules
yeah so so anyway I covered a lot of
data a lot of information I'm going to
send everyone a link to all these slides
because I have a lot of references that
you can see and I will send it out
probably a little bit later on probably
in the middle of a night you'll go go to
you and that way you can see the webinar
I mean all the slides and I'll send you
the webinar replay too if you want that
but I want you to apply some of the
information that I shared tonight and I
want to thank Leslie for being onto
sharing her story of the wonderful
example of trying to get some help of
treating one person at our once
condition and time so thank thank you
very much next Tuesday we're going to do
another seminar and this one's going to
be on energy and it's going to be really
awesome I'm going to cover the topic on
insulin very heavily you need to what
you need to see that if you have any
insulin problems and even eat if you
don't if you if you are fatigued you
need to come to this webinar as well um
so I'll show you some techniques as well
I'm going to show you an acupressure
technique that will literally increase
your energy yeah so I'm
demonstrate it right in my office right
here and then you could do it on your
friends and family just don't mention my
name
now I'm fine you can you can do that so
I want to thank you guys for showing up
tonight I and I will see you next and
the next webinar so I'll send you a link
on that too
and I will have someone reply to a lot
of your questions because some people
are having specific questions about this
and that so I'll try to answer those or
go to my blog but I want to say thank
you and have a great evening thanks
Lesley we'll see you next time thank you
you're welcome